>> My opinion on the question of role models
is, yes. I have lived in the region for a
year when I was younger in Kuwait, and then
I now live in Turkey, in Istanbul, responsible
for Middle East Africa for my company. I met
a wonderful example of role models actually
coming into this forum. Yesterday, as I was
at a queue next to an African lady and I asked
her what she did and she told me she was an
elective member of Afghanistans Parliment.
And I said what do you think your main achievement
has been, and she told me, being a member,
as a woman, in Afghanistans Parliment. I think
role models can play a very very important
part for the younger generation who look up
naturally to entrepeneurs, to gender diversity
and ask questions based on the framework of
the older generation as laid around them.
I think it's important for the Middle East
if it is to evolve into a dynamic, vibrant
model for the world, it must have role models
that break some of the frameworks and more
archaic systems that are in place already.
It is a natural state for any part of the
world, but one I think is extremely important
for the Middle East.